foreign
[Music]
that's me and you're probably wondering
how I ended up here well it's pretty
standard
check this out
[Music]
it's making everything sync up with the
beat
let's rock this is awesome
[Music]
that's the defense
what in the hell am I looking at the
name's chai not defects
we'll take down this company one boss at
a time
future Rockstar
thank you for all your support over the
years and I'm John Johannes director on
hi-fi Rush
chill out
before
um
[Music]
[Applause]
so everyone thinks of us as putting out
horror games like The Evil Within or
spooky games like ghostwire Tokyo but
this is clearly something totally
different and if this game hasn't
already leaked fingers crossed we hope
it's a pleasant surprise
let's have some fun
foreign
[Music]
so we've been waiting for this for a
long time so let's jump in and explain
exactly what Hi-Fi Rush is
[Music]
HiFi Rush is a rhythm action game so
it's a bit of a Twist on your
traditional action game here your moves
and attacks help create a living
soundtrack that means all your flashy
moves stylish and devastating combos add
a layer to the music
the more you flow with the beat the
better you can connect your attacks and
abilities
you are in total control during combat
but everything you do syncs up like an
awesome music video
that's HiFi Rush
you play as chai
I Wannabe Rockstar and victim of a weird
corporate experiment that lets him sense
the rhythm of the entire world pulsing
to the game soundtrack
[Music]
as you can see the beat moves the world
around you and is the key to combat you
looking for me your attacks will
automatically sink to land on the beat
making Hi-Fi Rush a super easy game to
start playing
however attacking on the beat leads to
combos that end with a musical countdown
we call a Beat hit think a big simple
crash at the end of a drum Zone like
this
Landing beat hits on the Chicago finish
that adds unique musical Flair and high
damage attacks
and The Crowd Goes Wild
child
oh
um
anyone see the guy that did this
[Music]
how about we see it all in action
Bring It On
[Music]
you're never restrained by the music you
can jump Dodge parry and attack whenever
you want using whatever attacks you want
it's not about mashing buttons
the key here is feeling the beat
[Applause]
[Music]
your progress isn't blocked by missing
the beat but you get rewarded musically
and mechanically for staying in rhythm
[Music]
when we say everything moves to the beat
we mean it enemy attacks
cutscenes
dangerous obstacles you name it
it all sinks to the music creating an
ongoing jam session of a game
[Music]
to help out is 808 your robot cat
companion literally hovers over your
shoulder and helps you find that rhythm
but we also have visual guides to help
you even more
[Music]
we want you to be able to enjoy Hi-Fi
Rush whether you're Rhythm Pro or not
I look so cool doing this
chai also gets by With a Little Help
from his friends
literally
get up slacker we've got work to do
chai will team up with unlikely allies
to expand his repertoire of moves both
in and out of combat there's peppermint
breaking barriers and juggling enemies
along with macarons smashing enemy armor
and knocking backhanded tag teaming with
chai's partners and attacks opens up
huge possibilities for dynamic Combos
and over-the-top action
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not bad
the extra help is handy because when
you're not fighting you're going to be
running around and wreaking havoc all
over vandelay's corporate headquarters
where everything is trying to take you
down you and your partners have a
singular goal in mind
taking down the bosses of vandelay
Technologies
besides wanting to race chai for being a
defect it seems they've got something a
little bit more Sinister on their
corporate agenda
you'll fight through each department to
take them all on each level with their
own musical spin on the Rock genre and
then we have a showdown
[Music]
so let's get ready to crumble boss
battles are climactic set pieces varying
from straight up fights and musical
minigames to chase sequences
custom Cruise app to licensed music from
amazing artists
[Music]
high five Rush is like nothing we've
made at Tango before
and we think it's like nothing you've
ever played before either
it's a high energy feel good Rhythm
action experience that's amazingly
satisfying to play
[Applause]
pretty rock star move shy
[Music]
Ness
so not only were you super psyched for
you to play this we're happy to tell you
that you can play Hi-Fi Rush tonight
not a demo the full game seriously
it launches on Xbox and PC a few hours
after the show and yes it'll be on Game
Pass as well
we hope you enjoy playing Nick
[Music]
you looking for me
mind if I join
does that mean I have to fight I believe
it does sir
how about that
this is entertaining you're going out
with the trash
here's your project Armstrong paths and
welcome to vandelay campus
[Music]